[music]
Candy truth. The ancient Athenian
festival of Cronia used to take place on
the 12th day of Hecat Bayon, the first
month of the Attic calendar, coincided
with the middle of summer and honored
the father god Kronos, considered a
patron of the harvest. Although it was
celebrated in the summer, it was a major
influence on the most popular Roman
festival, the famous Satnelia, dedicated
to Saturn, Cronis' Roman equivalent. The
festival of Saturnelia was initially
celebrated on the 17th of December, but
was later extended to three and
eventually to seven days until twrn.
It also included offerings, especially
of fruit and bread. The Satnelia was
also a public holiday associated with
merry drinking and exchanging of small
gifts such as candles, wax models of
fruit, and waxin statueets. In this case
too, the slaves were spared from their
usual tasks and took part in their
lively feast. People would also decorate
their homes with evergreen boughs and
sprigs of mistletoe, a symbol of eternal
life, but also love and peace. Many
considered the custom a predecessor of
Christmas wreaths, mistletoe decoration,
and even the tradition of the Christmas
tree. The Druids in ancient Celtic
priestly classes contribute significant
connections to the characters and
traditions of Christmas through their
practices and beliefs, particularly in
the context of tree worship, seasonal
rituals, and the use of sacred plants.
Their traditions align with many aspects
of Saturn Kronos, Woden, Krampus, and
even centerass reflecting how Celtic
paganism influenced the development of
modern Christmas. Tree worship and
sacred groves. The Druids revered trees,
particularly oak trees, as sacred.
Groves were often used for ceremonies,
including fertility rituals and
sacrifices.
This aligns with the tree worship
associated with Satnelia. Oh, Satnelian
and Ule traditions and the modern
Christmas tree, a practice adapted from
these um pagan customs. Saturn and
Kronos. Like the sacrifices to Saturn,
Druids performed offerings under sacred
trees during solstice rituals. Woden
Woden's association with the world tree
Yigdasel echoes the druidic reverence
for trees as cosmic connectors. Modern
Christmas tree. The druidic practice of
decorating and honoring trees influenced
the later Christmas tree tradition. The
candles in some parts of England lighted
on Christmas Eve and used so long as the
festival season lasts were equally
lighted by the pagans on the eve of the
festival of the Babylonian God to do
honor to him for it was one of the
distinguishing peculiarities of his
worship to have lighted wax candles on
his altars. The Christmas tree now so
common among us was equally common in
pagan Rome and pagan Egypt. Think of
that. Rome and Egypt. That's usually
where you go back to find occult things.
In Egypt, that tree was the palm tree.
In Rome, it was the fur. Now, think
back. Um, whoever asked the question
about the wreaths, now is the time to
think about those wreaths and what they
may be made out of, depending on certain
cultures and backgrounds or different
parts of the year. They're telling you
right now, in Egypt, it was the palm
tree. In Rome, it was the fur tree. The
palm tree denoted the pagan messiah as
Bale Tamar. The fur tree was referred to
him as Baal Barth, the mother of Adonis,
the sun god and great meditorial
divinity was mystically said to have
been changed into a tree and went in
that state to have brought forth her
divine son. So interesting. She was a
tree and then she had a son divinely. If
the mother was a tree, the son must have
been recognized as the the man the
branch. Interesting. And this entirely
accounts for the putting of the ule log.
Oh, how here we go. For the putting of
the u log into the fire on Christmas Eve
and the appearance of the Christmas tree
the next morning. Azerro Ashta, the seed
of the woman. I know that's a god that's
related to some religion. I forgot which
one. the seat of the woman which which
name also signified igna or born of the
fire. He has to enter the fire on mother
night. Okay, so think about this on
mother night that he may be born the
next day out of it as the branch of God
or the tree that brings all divine gifts
to men. But why, it may be asked, does
he enter the fire under the symbol of a
log? To understand this, it must be
remembered that the divine child born at
the winter solstice was born as a new
incarnation of the great god after that
god had been cut in pieces on purpose to
revenge his death upon his murderers. It
says, "Now the ulog is the dead stock."
It's like mid little more than halfway
down. Now the ulog is a dead stock of
Nimrod. Okay, so it's telling you right
away where it came from.
Correlating to the other piece that said
it was from Nimrod, which de was deified
as a sun god, but cut down by his
enemies. The Christmas tree is Nimrod,
bread of Vivas, the slain god come to
life again. In the light reflected by
the above statement on customs that
still linger among us, the origin of
which has been lost in the midst of
horror antiquity, let the reader look at
the singular practice still kept in the
south of Christmas Eve on Christmas Eve
of kissing under the mistletoe bow.
Okay, just a minute. We're going to get
into the mistletoe. the top of the next
page on the right. That mistletoe bow in
the druidic superstition
which as we have seen was derived from
Babylon was representation of the
Messiah. The man the branch the
mistletoe was regarded as a divine
branch. A branch that came from heaven
and grew up upon a tree that sprung out
of the earth. Thus by the engrafting of
the celestial branch into the earthly
tree, heaven and earth that sin had se
that sin had severed were joined
together and thus the mistletoe bow
became the token of divine
reconciliation to man. The kiss being
the well-known token of pardon and
reconciliation. They do indeed think
that you can actually be reborn under
the sun and the moon and the heavens as
a entity on earth. Most occult or pagan
people definitely believe that. So that
is exactly what they're wanting to
accomplish during this time. And the
ceremony of kissing under the mistletoe
is letting the mistletoe do its magic of
making you
in connection with the heavens to do so.
Plus, it also is said to make you
fertile so that whoever you're kissing,
you'll probably end up with that night.
Um, you might have children after that.
In the Norse, the word ule means wheel.
Now, this is for the sun wheel or the
pagan sunheel which the druids satanists
and witches use. That's where we derive
our holidays from. And in ancient
Calaldian or Babylonian, the word ule
means infant or little child. We will
see why. In old English, the word means
jolly. The concept of the old father
time and baby new year have these same
pagan overtones as well. Now, here's
where it gets pretty um dark. So, go
with me. Down below, u on the satanic
calendar, very down below on the page,
it says December's 22nd was winter
solstice or sab sabat festival or feast
day. This is unfortunately the time
which orgies occurred, oral, anal,
vaginal, in any age, male or female,
human or animal. December 24th is called
demon rebels. If you remember this from
my other coverings of the episodes on
holidays, it happens quite a few times
in a year. And this is when they um
encounter demons in their practices and
rituals and they do what's called deour.
They have a high grand climax and it's
just not good. It requires any age, male
or female, human and or animal as well.
And then you have Christmas Eve which
requires blood. On Christmas you would
receive gifts of body parts usually from
an infant male. This is why we call it
ule. This is why ule means infant or
little child. So that is the hardest and
worst part of this. What is the origin
of the nicolatians in revelation 2 6 and
15? Nicolation means a follower of
Nicholas. It comes from two Greek words
Nikos and Lois. Nikos means conqueror or
destroyer and Laos means people. The
original Nicholas was a conqueror or
destroyer of the people. Some people
believe that the original Nicholas was
Nimrod, the original ark rebel who
conquered the people and found a
man-made civil civilization within two
centuries after the flood. This is
actually cited in Genesis 108-12.
And while he was alive, Nimrod put
himself in the place of God. Or as a
biblical text puts it, he was a mighty
hunter before the Lord. When he died,
his admirers continued to worship him as
a divine hero. They called him Baal. A
name found throughout the Old Testament,
meaning master or lord. Nimrod also had
other names. One commonly used
throughout Asia Minor was Santa. This is
from the Lumpier's classical dictionary.
Santa Claus is but a shortened form of
Santa. Santa Nicholas or St. Nicholas.
Many unknowingly honor this Nicholas
even in our daytoday by observing
customs associated with December 25th.
Christmas originally was a satinelia or
birthday of Nimrod. Very true. Of
course, these customs handed down from
ancient paganism have been renamed and
made to appear innocent and good. Others
think that the Nicholas mentioned in
Revelation 2 is the man called Nicholas,
a procelite from Antioch, which is
ordained a deacon early in the church's
history in Acts 6 1-6. Writings of the
time say that he later came to follow
Gnostic teachings and became an
aesthetic and many followed his new
doctrines. Taking all this into account,
let's then look at the very left in my
Bible verses that I have. So in
revelation 2:15-6
it says likewise you also have those who
hold to the teachings of the niclatians.
Repent therefore otherwise I will soon
come to you and will fight against them
with the sword of my mouth. The next
verse I have is Revelation 26. But this
thou hast that thou hatest the deeds of
the nicicoatans which I also hate. This
is from Miam Webster dictionary and it
just tells you right out the only thing
they're saying here is it's used as a
name of the devil. Synonyms Belub,
Lucifer, fiend, devil, Satan, and
serpent. And I thought it was
interesting to note that it is actually
considered this since circa
1643.
That's a long time. It's nothing new.
This is also proof from an old
encyclopedia dictionary that also says,
"But old Nick means the devil." The tree
is a big topic. One need not spend long
hours in research to find people
throughout history have incorporated
trees into their religious activities.
The tree being the largest of plants
readily lends itself to ma majesty in
the na the worship sorry in the worship
of nature. Sometimes the tree itself is
worshiped. Here's where we need to pay
attention. Please perk up. Oh, sometimes
the tree itself is woripped.
Listen, listen closely. Other times the
tree is viewed as a conduit to the god,
a god or an object integral to the
religious operations. Sometimes an altar
is set up but beneath a tree or other
times the tree is the altar. Does this
make anyone else cringe? Venerated trees
are often called groves. This is true
whether one is speaking of a group of
trees or a single tree. They just blew
that cover because people go, "Oh," they
go, you know, I only have one tree in my
house and that's only around Christmas
time. And from what they're saying, even
just one cut down in your in your house
is called a grove and is an altar. In
pagan writes, the grove is also is often
often listen often a single tree and the
grove can be in the forest among other
trees or it can be moved indoors. Okay.
Historically, groves were often
dedicated to one or more pagan gods.
That is true. Offerings were either
placed beneath the grove like the
Christmas custom of placing presents
beneath a tree or were hung from the
branches of a tree like the Christmas
custom of decorating a tree. Offerings
must be intended for the grove. Okay, to
the gods basically or the pagan god
associated with the grove. All right, so
there really is coming from a pagan
standpoint. You have a grove. You have a
tree in your house. uh you can't get any
you can't get around that that you
actually are you have an altar in your
house and offerings of gifts underneath
that tree or on that tree that are meant
for the grove and the gods associated
with the grove. Let's continue. As it
says in the second paragraph to last,
the ancient Assyrians had their sacred
trees which they purified by sprinkling
with mulu or pine cone which had been
dipped into a sacred bucket
called a band dudu as depicted in the
image of the relief here that was in the
original article by God made us. So I'm
not sure what relief they are
mentioning, but the relief in this image
is dated to the reign of Ashure Naser
Paul II, who ruled from 883 to 859.
That relief is a direct physical
evidence that trees were decorated and
included in religious rights nearly a
thousand years before the birth of our
Lord and Savior, which directly
contradicts any notion that the
Christmas tree was developed for the
celebration of Christ's birth. This
relief also shows the religious
operations involving a tree with leaves
or needles, refuting the popular
assertion that pagan practices only
involve the use of a bare stick or
maple. This relief was made with in
about 250 years of when Jeremiah penned
his description of groves in Jeremiah
verse or chapter 10. We will get to that
in just a minute. It gives us an image
to go with Jeremiah's description. Some
of the world's oldest and most read
texts also mention the groves from which
the Christmas tree gets its roots.
Homer's Iliad is thought to have been
written somewhere around 1200 BC. In it,
Homer reveals one of the most familiar
descriptions of ancients worshiping at
altars beneath the tree. So as for that
verse in Jeremiah 10 3-4, it says, "For
the customs of the people are vain, for
one cutth a tree out of the forest, the
work of the hands of the workmen with
the axe. They deck it with silver and
gold, and they fasten it with nails and
hammers that it move not." Okay, so
we're clearly not supposed to do this as
the customs of the people. Which people?
Well, the customs of the pagan people
that God always warns us not to follow.
The point here is that God, many people
would say God made the pine tree,
therefore it can't be evil. And so,
unfortunately, it doesn't work that way.
We can't take another idol or God and
repurpose it to worship God. It doesn't
work that way. So, let's just look at
the verse. It says, "Take heed to
thyself that thou be not snared by
following them, after that they be
destroyed from before thee, and that
thou inquire inquire not after their
gods, saying, How did these nations
serve their gods? And even so will I do
likewise? Thou shalt not do so unto the
Lord thy God, for every abomination to
the Lord, which he hateth, have they
done unto their gods. For even their
sons and their daughters they have burnt
in the fire to their gods." Yes. Ule
meaning infant or child. Not only were
they kind of cut into pieces and
delivered as gifts on Christmas, but the
u log might have actually represented
burning your children in the fire as
well. Now it's to today it's not so
gruesome, but it's not it's still not
benign. We have a ulog cake that we eat
instead instead of burning a log
usually. Anyway, continuing on. What
things soever I command you, observe to
do it. Thou shalt not add thereto nor
diminish from it. So we are not to do as
the pagans do worshiping their gods.
Here's the idea that Cain was doing the
same. He was repurposing and trying to
worship God in his own way by bringing
produce to sacrifice instead of what God
asked. God has specific ways in which he
wants us to worship him. We can't
repurpose other ways of doing so or
pagan ways of doing so. So it says,
"Cain brought of the fruit of the ground
an offering unto the Lord, and Abel he
also brought of the firstlings of his
flock, and of the fat thereof. And the
Lord had respect unto Abel, and to his
offering. But unto Cain and to his
offerings, he had not respect." So God
does not respect if you try to take
something else and make it a way to
worship him. And the and Cain was very
wroth, and his countenance fell. That is
the the takeaway from this. We are not
supposed to do as the pagans do. Many
people will make excuses. Even though
they said that they wanted another god
to worship while Moses was on the hill,
they still said it was a feast onto the
Lord. You just cannot repurpose it. You
cannot worship God in a way he tells he
tells you not to. It's still pagan. So,
you can't repurpose where Christmas came
from and try to separate it from that.
create dissonance in you so you don't
know and think about it anymore and just
do it just like anyone else is doing. At
least if you really want to worship God,
you can't do that because he knows it's
idolatry. He knows it's paganism. And I
hate to say that because I grew up with
it. But once I became an adult, I saw
through it very quickly. And I think
it's important. It's very important to
God not to worship idols. So there is no
excuse. There's no way we can
substantiate doing so in our life. Let's
make God proud and make him the Lord of
our life by not worshiping other things
and putting these holidays that worship
other gods in our